I welcome to Hannity so the shift show
is back in action the circus remains in
town today another national disgrace
what we saw again every American needs
to see this abs pathetic show trial zero
substance zero facts zero get this
first-hand knowledge nothing zero zip
nada and of course no due process we got
a judge jury and executioner his
Highness we got the compromise corrupt
coward congenital liar Adam Schiff oh he
was in rare form today
take a look mister phonic Thank You mr.
Nunez ambassador Jovanovic thank you for
being here today
the gentlewoman will suspend what is the
interruption for this time it is our
time the gentleman will suspend
recognized under the house resident 660
you are not allowed to yield time except
to minority can ranking member yielded
time to another member of Congress we're
not recognized this is the fifth time
you have interrupted members will
suspend
welcome to the Wow which trial led by
the congenital liar
by the way what's he so afraid of oh
that's right the truth that's what he's
terrified of and that's why we didn't
hear from an actual fact witness again
she knew nothing as never noona said why
was she even there we just get more
testimony more testimony yes another
self-important very narcissistic
diplomat snowflake who can't take minor
tiny baby criticism not a witness to
nothing she had no reason to be there
she witnessed no wrongdoing knew nothing
about what we're discussing no direct
evidence of any misconduct whatsoever no
contact with the president no contact
with his chief of staff no contact with
anybody that really knew the president
no knowledge of anything being alleged
by the Democrats you cannot make this
sick this up this is how sick Washington
has become were you involved in the July
25th Trump's
skee phone call or preparations for the
call no I was not
were you involved in the deliberations
about the pause and military sales to
Ukraine as the Trump administration
reviewed newly elected president
olenski's commitment to corruption
reforms for the delay in for the pause
the pause no I was not
were you involved in the proposed Trump
szalinski later pin Solinsky meetings in
Warsaw Poland on September 1st no I was
not did you ever talk to President Trump
in 2019 no I have not
Mick Mulvaney no I have not Thank You
ambassador yeah then he says why the
hell was she even there oh that's right
she was fired her feelings were hurt she
expressed that a lot and she had a lot
of nice things to say about the
president by the way President Obama got
rid of ambassadors to this whole entire
charade none of it is about truth or
justice it is about a never ending
three-year smear of this president at
all costs because they cannot accept the
results in 2016 and as a consequence
well the House Democrats they have done
nothing
oh and government funding is set to
expire next week funding for our
military set to expire next week an
important trade agreement with Canada
and Mexico is yet to be approved these
do-nothing Democrats they've done
nothing for three years are ignoring
really serious issues let's see peace
and safety and security and prosperity
and job creation
why because of this psychotic rage at
the mere mention of Donald Trump and all
the ambassadors she even admitted they
serve at the pleasure of the President
of the United States and President Obama
he fired dozens of ambassador holdovers
from the bush administration and he did
it for political reasons nobody
criticized him a president has the right
to fire or hire any ambassador for any
reason or no reason at all as a matter
of fact there was good reason to want
today star witness removed former pose
look at these interviews conducted by
John Solomon and the New York Times a
top Ukrainian prosecutor has repeatedly
claimed she gave him a do not prosecute
list in 2016 now the former ambassador
denies the accusation there was one
paper I believe in Ukraine that said he
rescinded those remarks we'll ask John
Solomon about it in a second
do I know who's telling the truth no I
do not how does any of this apply to
impeaching a president duly elected
president of the United States it
doesn't